what is quantum mechanics oh yes sure so
quantum mechanics
so i i i discussed briefly when i talked
about the connection between newtonian
mechanics
and the euler lagrange formulation of of
the newtonian mechanics and
interpretation of this
euler grunge uh formalism in terms of
the paths that the particle take
so when we say a particle goes from here
to here
we usually think it classically it
follows a specific trajectory but
actually in quantum mechanics it falls
follows every trajectory
with different probabilities and so
there's this fuzziness
now most probable it's the path that you
actually see
and the deviation from that is very very
unlikely and probabilistically very
minuscule
so in everyday experiment we don't see
anything deviated from what we expect
but quantum mechanics tells us that the
things are more fuzzy things are
are not as precise as the line you draw
things are a bit like cloud so if you go
to microscopic
uh scales like atomic scales and lower
these phenomena become more pronounced
you can see it much better the electron
is is not at the point
but the clouds spread out around the
nucleus and so this fuzziness this
probabilistic aspect
of reality is what quantum mechanics
describes
you